okay what up guys welcome to the just
pearly things YouTube channel and
welcome to morning coffee thoughts
although today my coffee's being
delivered so I just have water but you
never know it'll come before I start
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
and ring that notification Bell that we
are going to be notified of my daily
videos I think my roommate might still
be asleep so I'm trying to be a little
bit quieter in case
um okay guys this is probably the worst
I've ever looked on camera
if I looked at it it's because I am
do you know what I've gone through this
week
so a certain someone
sent me an invitation to interview him
in Dubai and I was supposed to go and I
was very excited and I
decided to fly out three girls
um to be on the panel with us
um it was going to be my 100th episode
I felt like this video would get me to a
million or close to it by New Year's
um which was you know my goal I think
we're kind of far away because we're at
800k but I was like you never know which
just takes one stupid viral video right
and
um
I mean to be fair my New Year's
resolution last year was 100K so you
know I did beat that
um however
um this week what happened was we had
five people from our team going
um well including the other girls
six including me six okay and got their
hotels got their flights got everything
ready
and what happened was my manager went
there and I woke up to your text
um yesterday morning saying that he had
been detained
because because
I think it's Americans
we're just so used to everyone letting
us into their countries he brought a
emergency passport
um which I guess doesn't work in Dubai I
on the other hand have a passport that
expires in a couple months and I guess
they don't accept that either in Dubai
um
and it's like I could risk it but do I
want to waste all that time and make
just to maybe get detained at the border
I don't know about that so
um my point is
it's not looking good but I stayed up
all night
to which I shouldn't have but I was up
late anyway because my expenses have
gotten out of control in this business
and I was up with my dad going through
them and then it was like late enough
and I was just scared I wasn't gonna
wake up in time so I was like afraid to
fall asleep so it's like [ __ ] it I'll
just stay up all night
for my passport appointment to see if
maybe
I can get a passport but I think the
only one they can give me is an
emergency passport so I don't think I'm
going to Dubai
sadly so
um a lot of plans are ruined um but on
the other hand my manager was detained
for like 20 hours so
at least that didn't happen to me now
he's got a 24-hour flight back my Lord
oh my God they couldn't pay me to take a
24-hour flight I'd be like send me
anywhere else
um anyways
so next
uh what happened next
so this month
it's been difficult I want to lie to you
guys like
lately I really want to get to a million
and that's my goal but I feel like
lately I've just been getting like tired
and the thing is with a lot of like the
people you guys see
um
you know they have a co-host or they
have
um
people I don't I just my team is a lot
um the smaller than a lot of people
and my goal is to make it to hire things
out so I'm less stressed but lately it's
just been hard and I think it's even
harder because I feel like when you
start to get successful everyone like
sort of wants a piece
and it's like
they want a piece they want a piece they
want a peace they want a piece and
ah and it's hard because again people
think there's more than there is like
I'll give you an example most people
don't know in a business you want to
save up six months worth of expenses I
learned this from my dad so it's like
first thing I did when I made money
was I spent more than I realized like a
stupid amount
on equipment and probably more than I
should if I think we have the best
podcast
um video audio everything was in this
space uh you know but let me tell you we
paid for that so that was like where the
first of like the money I made went
right and then um and before that it was
people and then
next my next goal is to save up six
months worth of expenses so that's in
case there's a recession like ad rates
go down after
Christmas and so you know you don't
if you don't have six months of expenses
that's how people go under that's how
you start having to let people go
you know nothing that anyone like wants
so
that's my I'm sorry I'm checking my
coffee really quick and so my point is a
lot of people don't know that so they
look at socialblade and they just see
what you're doing how you're doing and
they're just like
you know it's just like everyone
everyone wants a piece
and the other problem I have as a woman
is I think there's things in
management that I'm not really built or
meant to do
and in all honesty I think if I could
have started this from the beginning and
worked for someone I really would have
preferred that
um
I really don't like being censored on
what I can I can't say so but from like
a management perspective it's never
something I've like aspired to or wanted
to do it's just something I kind of got
like thrown into
um
and I really don't like it and I think
as women like
a lot of times
it's like you're kind of trying to be
something that you're not because if
you're a manager you're super
you kind of have to be a little bit of a
dick and I think as women we're more
agreeable I know the comments will say
you don't have to be
and I will let you guys know I'm on zero
hours of sleep so if I sound
discombobulated it's literally because I
am
um
but
yeah I just think there's some problems
that are like meant for men
and women aren't meant to have these and
I went into this knowing that long-term
like
it just wasn't meant for me and I'll
give you guys an example so I I consult
with my brothers a lot
and my dad
um
he was talking to me today about the
differences between how my brothers and
me
um
react to problems and he was just saying
that like when I get too many things
thrown at me at once like I kind of get
stressed out and then I get really
frustrated and that's how I react where
like the boys you can kind of put them
in a stressful situation and and they
can like do this this and this and I
really think it's like more of like a
men
versus like women thing I don't know
um and I'm sure there's some women that
are good at it it's just not naturally
mean
um
so
yeah that's the other thing I was going
to talk about
the other thing is I think recently I've
just been like really homesick
um
and it's good because I'm going home for
Christmas but
I realized like I need to move
everything to the U.S and it's like the
amount of work it's going to take to
move everything to the U.S
Oh I wanna I wanna I Wanna Cry thinking
about it because I just like want to be
closer to my sisters and my brothers and
I want to be closer to my family and
this year like I missed Christmas or not
Christmas Thanksgiving
for the first time because it just
didn't make sense of my volleyball
schedule to go I don't know it's just
going to take time but as I told my dad
you know women's emotions change daily
so maybe tomorrow I'll be like no I love
London
because I do I feel like I'll always
have love for this city but I just feel
like it's time to go
next thing
um
I don't even know if I'll post this
because it has my alarm to make sure I
was up because
yeah
um next thing I want to talk about is
something random I learned this week and
you'll see me learn it and the reactions
um basically in the U.S the abuse system
for men and I forgot what it was called
but it was the system that these three
feminists
um
came up with and it basically was like
a scam in a way because the the system
basically said that they defaulted to
women being the victims and men being
the perpetrators and I guess all of the
laws like derived from the system and
the women were saying it themselves that
it didn't what they were preaching
didn't really match up with what they
saw
and so it's kind of like
messed up
um
that all of the laws are like
based on that
again guys I'm tired I
I don't know number four number four
fourth thing I want to talk about today
um the cities I'm thinking about moving
to
so
um there's four cities
no no maybe five I don't know so the
cities I was thinking about
I really feel called to Nashville and I
have a feeling that's where I'm going to
end up mostly because I just really love
country music and it's like sunny and I
really want to go somewhere Sunny
because I I feel like I'm so pale I look
sickly here
um
second thing I want to go
um to
maybe Dallas or Austin
um
maybe floored my parents have a house in
Florida so and I think there's no income
taxes there
um Vegas isn't completely off but I know
I just don't think I wouldn't like Vegas
no no no no my brother lives in Utah
though so I was like ah maybe but
probably not probably not I'll probably
stay Midwest I think that's where
I lived in Milwaukee for a while I
actually really liked Milwaukee but yeah
that's that's the coffee thoughts of the
day sorry if this is like low energy and
tired
I'm just trying to pass the time until
my appointment which is soon so let me
know what you guys want me to talk about
next in the comments um subscribe to the
channel ring that notification Bell and
I'll talk to you next time